[la musique]
mars un pour moi est debout et fisting
exposition développer un rapide et essayer
être
pixeden capital et est-ce un
le sud commence à être unique ce genre
trappe de démarrage jusqu'à présent
obtenir skype Reuters
les sociétés autonomes semblent reprises par des asiatiques
les grandes villes utilisent leurs ventes sla
Winslow
aidan comme allons en 59 finale
ici dobson a réussi un peu et même tache
bien sûr et j'ai dit que tu étais stupide
davi belle être pour la guerre mondiale
[la musique]
il y a beaucoup d'endroits à Varsovie qui
rappelle la Seconde Guerre mondiale
[la musique]
ça a commencé avec l'attaque contre la Pologne
La Seconde Guerre mondiale et la Pologne ont pris le relais
toi-même le premier coup
le coup le plus fort du ghetto nazi de prague
c'est un endroit terrible où les gens ont été amenés
de toute la Pologne et aussi de pas
canal europe de l'ouest
qui est arrivé là, ils avaient un billet pour
une extrémité
une partie importante de la population a été torturée
ce ghetto
c'est une tragédie incroyable pour la parole des gens
il s'agit de centaines et de milliers
qui ont fini leur vie ici dehors
conditions humaines angoissantes
[la musique]
une fois ici serait son ghetto de Varsovie
mais la Varsovie moderne se construit et trace
l'histoire passée s'efface peu à peu
la mémoire des gens
Je veux croire que la construction rapide
la ville part encore et
lieu de mémoire pour la mémoire humaine
rappelant aux gens qu'il y en avait d'autres
les temps étaient effrayants les temps difficiles il
pas d'échange de contact avec qui chattes
sol et sa main faite en une seule et
rouler pour mettre l'index mlm jusqu'à tutorat
l'importance officielle de l'acte un moment est
mieux pour toi
et le film lui-même enga échantillon
[la musique]
autres fichiers oui oui deux
baiser sur une seule ai où il noir sur
colombe blanche sur les positions en direct
union dps vol ford noir sur blanc
chansons de fouineur
et voila le show pour passer la dualité av av et wi-fi
de la nature humaine du monde
modèle et dans un homme presse homme
nivka to-to site
Dagu n'entre pas dans le côté obscur
ombre du site downlight sur le soleil
la vie humaine et le monde sont très fragiles
les choses sont si minces entre le monde
et la guerre
[la musique]
dans une certaine situation dans certains
conditions idéologiques personnes de
civilisé
deviennent très vite des bêtes qui
oublier toutes les règles humaines
la vie
mais dans tous les aspects humains de leur vie
La scène de Mike est ici
d'un demi-morceau d'humain d'un b
rochers avant le but était le plus
écraser l'année qui a le plus donné 5 . site bougie
et en un instant
oui avec le vôtre vous vous trompez rappelez doha si
tu ne t'es pas souvenu de la danse elle-même 1:00 out
les couples peuvent ouvrir le petit site à l'ombre
et le mien est accepté pour synchrone si
Tu recherches
mais les tribunaux de la bouche fantôme
il a donné le fonds ssd à froid à son nx
inspirer éclairage baida stan baida
soldats en des jours comme
pendant la fin du monde serait de
cours pour fautif pour lui et
garder ceci est une chose importante
devrait te donner du sable
[la musique]